[Music]
it's 2006. this is referee Horacio
Elizondo giving a red card to Zinedine
Zidane because he head-butted Marco
matarazzi due to budget concerns let's
say this is the video of it happening
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
this really was a big deal it has been
sculpted but this isn't the only famous
part of that match
[Music]
it also featured zidane shooting one of
the greatest penalty kicks of all time
across the line
what happens when you strip away all the
emotion and psychology and chance of a
penalty kick and look at the data where
is the best spot to place a penalty kick
in football the beautiful game the
penalty kick places a player here
against a keeper
a penalty kick shootout helps decide a
game in the event of a tie it's the same
thing but with kickers from each team in
succession to see which team scores the
most after five chances a PK shootout
from Spain 1982 looks pretty similar to
one in Russia in 2018 or Qatar in 2022
so you could record every PK shootout
shot and find out which spot worked best
the most frustrating part was uh you
know finding the video I remember I
think it was a West Germany match once I
found it I actually struggled just to
see where the ball went which is kind of
crazy if you think about it because
that's how people watching the games
like they had no idea what was happening
yeah exactly Pablo Lopez Landeros is a
data scientist in sports obsessive
hobbyist who recorded every World Cup
shootout kick from 1982 to 2018. I had
to watch the same shootout from five
different videos If I could find it
those shootouts provided a lot of data
he recorded the team the foot the kicker
shot with where the keeper went whether
the ball was on target or not if it did
go in and if it was an elimination goal
fans get kind of angry when a match
comes to a penalty shootout just because
they feel like it's a coin flip but if
you look at the data then it's a very
unfair coin flip just because 70 of the
goals uh go in Keepers affected that
they Dove to the left from the player's
perspective more than they Dove right
they often dive before seeing a shot's
trajectory so it can really be worth
knowing the probabilities they stayed in
the middle only about 13 percent of the
time where the save percentage was also
the lowest these stats work in concert
with where the kicks ended up
if you divide the goal into nine common
zones it's possible to see where players
kick the most for all shots including
misses the lower Corners were the most
common targets but that doesn't mean
they were best these are the success
rates by Zone and there are clear Trends
the top middle has a high Miss rate
likely a combination of it getting
stopped by the keeper or missing the
goal completely like in this classic
shot from a 1994 penalty kick shootout
meanwhile the most popular area that
lower left corner actually has a lower
success rate than the opposite corner
the top spot is that top right corner
where 88 percent of shots in World Cup
shootouts resulted in a goal
when you combine the keeper Dives with
the shooting data that right side looks
like it's undervalued by kickers so is
that The Final Answer always shoot it
there if you can there's two approaches
in in statistics two main like schools
of thought I guess the frequentest
approach which is like the clear-cut
example of what we're doing just uh
getting ratios looking at the data and
then there there's this other approach
uh called the Bayesian approach a
Bayesian might look at increasingly
complex predictors rather than a count
it could go on forever from the
footedness of the kids to the country
the kicker is playing
let's go back to the 1976 European
football championship
Czechoslovakia versus West Germany
this is Antonin panenka and he's holding
this trophy because of a penalty kick
strategy that he basically invented
he approaches looks normal you think
he'll hit it hard in that top right
corner
the keeper Dives
but look paninka has just gently tapped
it in
today that's known as a peninka kick
[Music]
it's a bluff in poker a bunting baseball
a fake punt in that game with the oblong
brown ball you can have data that
suggests that the top right corner or
even those Center zones are kind of
undervalued but ultimately the penalty
kick is a head game
which brings us back to zidane in 2006
that greatest penalty kick of all time
it wasn't a cannon to the top right he
approached the keeper Dove to that
statistically likely lower left corner
while zidane casually sailed it through
the center a panenka kick where it hit
the goal post and crossed the line into
history
[Applause]
yeah or we just have to like reach
without touching the table
[Music]
gosh